[Music]
what is up guys my name's labo and this
is a review for suicide guy for the iron
Lords podcast just as a bit of a
disclaimer we did receive this game for
free so there you go
so premise what is suicide that well
suicide guy is a three-dimensional
puzzle game in which you solve puzzles
with the aim of killing your character
by the end of the level hence the name
suicide guy pretty straightforward and
so our story goes the story of this game
is that you are a guy suicide guy and
you fall asleep but right before you
fall asleep your beer falls off the
table and you must save your beer and
falling by waking up now in order to
wake up you have to progress through
various levels solve puzzles each one
making you kill yourself so you can
leave yourself to the next level and
it's not Shakespeare as you can tell
like I said the aim of level like I said
the aim of each level is to kill
yourself and that's basically with a
game play goes you each level asks you
to solve a different type of puzzle some
levels will have you kill yourself by
falling from a great height other ones
will have you get crushed by things a
lot of them have you getting eaten or
like killed by like something else but
whatever the the premise is that your
character must die now to be completely
and utterly honest when I was playing
this game the biggest thing that I ran
into that caused a lot of like annoyance
had to be the physics the physics ending
in this game is just I don't know what
they used to make this game but it's
really wonky whatever is going on there
from an optimization standpoint because
number one this game doesn't respond
very well to gravity sometimes you'll
have blocks that you need to use to
solve the puzzle let's say in a UFO
level the aim of the level is take your
UFO and crash it into the Sun okay but
in order to do that you must go into it
if a part of the ship and you know
restore power to the
directional thingy whatever it's not
very clear and in order to do that you
must stack blocks on top of each other
to get back onto a higher platform well
the problem with this is that the graph
the gravity in this game doesn't
recognize very well when one block is on
all of another so I'm going to be
pushing a block the bottom one and the
top one will start sliding off as though
it has no weight at all and you today oh
oh but it's outer space the wampum of
course it doesn't have any good no
everything else in the game has gravity
in that level all right you're you don't
jump any higher nothing else no it
there's definitely gravity on the ship
it just does not recognize that the
blocks have weight and at that that's
weird it's really where there's other
villages that happen to with like
there's a forklift level and the boxes
would glitch out and one time like the
box like flew into the air onto a
different platform and we just couldn't
use that block anymore it was really
weird
umm so yeah there is this definite lack
of polish when it comes to the physics
in this game but did it stop me from
having a good time not always some of
the puzzles definitely felt genuinely
tough and you know you get that aha
moment at the end which I which I really
do you know desire in a puzzle game that
makes sense
the there were definitely some levels
that weren't like that there's some of
them there was like okay why why is this
the way to trigger my death like I don't
understand but I mean for those were few
and far between so I'm not gonna not
gonna rag too much on that it was mainly
just like two levels that I experienced
that were really like why does that work
so there's that also this game has
platforming which it should not have
platforming I don't know I don't know
yeah from a graphical standpoint the
game looks fine it's just it's just fine
it there's nothing really remarkable
there the only thing that really bothers
me is that a lot of the things other
than suicide guy don't have shadows
which leaves it looking like very
surreal and like really off-putting and
I really couldn't like I really didn't
notice that was what was working
until my friend Lewis pointed out that
the acids in the game just don't have
shadows and there's weird a lot of them
don't and so you know music wise there
are these radios scattered out doing
levels they have the levels music
playing through them and you can pick up
the radios and turn them off or on and
there's that so nothing particularly
noteworthy about the music in this game
it's just there however sound is very
like the sound effects are very strange
in that some sound effects are really
really loud like suicide guys like
grunts and footsteps they're just really
really loud and constantly there so that
can get a little annoying but so you
just turn those down and you you're
probably good so overall it's just it's
a fun little quirky game and it is what
it is it's dark humor if you like dark
humor you'll probably enjoy that but
it's not it's not gruesome or anything
like that like it's not there's no blood
or guts or anything it's it's very very
tame for a game called suicide y-you can
also consider this like a mini like walk
through here and I'm gonna talk about
the various the game here because I
think some of them bear mentioning
control wise you can use the d-pad to
not that you to ever want to but you can
it is an option to do so so this one is
letting us know that we can go through
this door here
Crouch here through this duct all the
movie alien remember that I'm like 57
that was a good movie alright so I did
actually play this game a little bit
beforehand before I started alright
started doing this and so this level I
remember this level just being a
absolute pain in the butt so hopefully I
can I can get this done a little bit
faster here it's kind of sucks because I
like no I would never want to stream a
puzzle game because you're gonna look
like a freaking idiot if you don't know
like there's always gonna be that one
person watching it's like now I don't
know if I'm actually supposed to
complete it this way but no let me get
the bottom one I'm just gonna drag it
very slowly over it because for some
reason the physics engine in this game
does not recognize that the gravity or
something I don't know I don't know what
it does but it also might be because
it's space but I doubt that because I
feel like I run into this kind of issue
all the time so we're gonna go and just
even though I don't think I actually
need you and now that I think about it I
don't need to do this I just need to get
it over to the other wall I'm just gonna
nudge it over okay just got to make sure
this stays on top of there and we're
just gonna keep pushing just gonna keep
on pushing
I think that's good no and I'm gonna
activate this deal because this is some
sort of Power Cell thing eat come on
let's go Bessie oh my goodness
I might have you play a level Louis just
see if you--if you're smart enough to
complete this game yes
basically yeah no oh yeah this was where
the statue was like I said like they're
not and they're not hidden particularly
I gotta find the Sun or something okay
where is it
if you like you run into an adventure
than they can remember okay no other way
ye and then we eat ourselves into the
Sun yeah and you die yeah so you can
tell like the graphics in this game
aren't super advanced it is it's a case
of it is what it is and so like I said I
will give this game props for for
concept execution
so I just want to see like because I've
played this level before so I'm going to
let and let Lewis handle and see if he
if he can handle yeah he shows just kill
yourself just change it back hit plus
there you go
look at you that's the way it's supposed
to be yeah I play inverted shut up
huh no you got there's no zombies use it
that's just a stupid speaker box and you
should really turn it off because music
is trash yeah you're trying to get bear
I will tell you this though you are
going backwards you're surveying the
land okay I'm sorry yeah it never has
any it's literally just the levels music
yeah
you-you'd you hit a is how you pick
things up I don't want to give away
because I feel like if I give away then
you wouldn't appreciate it
you gotta watch your mouth we're on
somebody else's Channel
yeah there's clearly a keyhole on it
gosh it's like watching a freaking
infant I think you probably dropped yeah
I think you have to keep facing it or
something I don't know you trying to
sprint sprint to this gauge is perpetual
crouching oh my god
I'm gonna make a video game called I
don't know the controls in which like
it's a multiplayer competitive game but
every time a new round starts all the
controls are swapped with another button
yeah alright so this is what I was
talking about before in that like this
kind of game has platforming and you'll
see what I mean like
you can also turn down this entity I had
it on like the defaults was so slow yeah
yeah we don't judge people you don't
know
yeah why is how you use items that
observation so just turn it down it's a
key all right here we go
here we go all right wonder what's in it
it's a hyper-realistic skull in a game
with a cartoon guy you know it looks
like Indiana Jones I think that's what
it is supposed to be you trying to pick
up that slingshot again the slingshot
him like he's never been slingshot there
are not but you wouldn't that be good
yeah there's no lights in here
you know if you if you hold a you can
throw things there we go I think you
missed the there you go all right you
ready you ready for the most annoying
crap you ever freaking see in your life
[Laughter]
no as long as that's there it'll stay
there and that is what happened to me
like 40 times no but it doesn't matter
though like I'm telling you you'll see
what I mean like there's a weird delay
just turn down the sensitivity
[Music]
now you gotta finish what are you doing
yeah I don't think you need to I think
you can just climb with it but I'm not
sure I can't remember yeah for some
reason with your third arm yeah it's
true does seem like he has telepathic
powers but he is like in a dream world
right now so maybe that explains this
telekinetic me all right it's actually
really pissing me off how easily you're
getting through this because I'm telling
you I felt like 40 freakin times yes yes
yes start over it's a kilobyte
I'm rooting for you kind of sorta right
wouldn't that be nice
Oh
[Laughter]
you die I do the next one
honest you
you
yep
and I refreshed just to see
I love just love how you refuse we
refuse to change the sensitivity
you gotta go back
I've played that you know this is right
and reminds me of like in all honesty
and I don't mean this to like offend any
of the developers anything like that
obviously you just took someone some
amount of time to make right my whole
thing is this really reminds me of like
you remember Newgrounds this seems like
a game that would be on Newgrounds calm
yeah a game in which you have to like
find a way to kill yourself that seems
like a very Newgrounds thing ever like
whack your boss and stuff like that
that's very scary I already got it
[Music]